Salut, après un an et demi
de vidéos, de spectacles
et d'écriture de livre
j'ai décidé de faire une pause
cet été
pour me reposer, oui
mais aussi pour vous préparer
une renaissance de la chaîne
en septembre.
Je vous ai demandé sur Twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facts rapides
et divertissants,
en attendant.
Alors, pendant ces 60 jour de pause,
je vous laisse une vidéo rapide
et sans prétention
tous les jours pairs
à 11h !
On se retrouve à la rentrée.
Et... tout de suite.
Salut.
Je suis persuadé que vous connaissez
les Darwin Awards
qui est une récompense
un petit peu glauque
pour récompenser les pires morts.
Vous connaissez aussi,
peut-être, les "Gérard"
qui récompensent les pires
animateurs télé
ou les plus mauvaises émissions ;
Et bien il y a aussi la même chose
pour le Prix Nobel,
ça s'appelle le Ig Nobel.
Parce que ça fait :
Ignobel.
Et depuis 1991, tous les ans,
ils décernent une dizaine de prix.
Un petit peu atypiques...
et qui ne paraissent pas toujours utiles.
2014 : IgNobel de physique
à des chercheurs japonais
qui ont consacré leurs recherches
à calculer le frottement entre
une peau de banane et une chaussure ;
entre une peau de banane
et le sol ;
et enfin, le Graal ultime :
le frottement d'une personne qui marche
sur une peau de banane posée sur le sol.
La science avance.
2016 : IgNbel de médecine
pour des allemands qui,
au terme de leurs recherches,
se sont rendu compte
qu'on pouvait transformer
une démangeaison du côté droit
au côté gauche.
Par exemple, çe ma gratte là
je peux le transférer là.
En se regardant dans un miroir et en se grattant
de l'autre côté qui nous gratte...
Est-ce que c'est bien clair c't'histoire ?
Si ça me gratte à droite,
je me regarde dans un miroir
et je me gratte du côté gauche.
Voilà...
2015 : IgNobel de chimie
à des chercheurs australiens
grâce à eux,
on a une méthode pour
dé-cuire un oeuf.
C'est à dire, un oeuf cuit :
on peut le dé-cuire.
Et çà...
béééé...
C'est bien !
Je suppose...
2012 : IgNobel de la dynamique des fluides !
Des chercheurs,
aux États-Unis
ont consacré leurs recherches,
leurs temps et leur budget...
pour étudier ce qu'il se passe
au niveau du ballottement des liquides
quand une personne marche
avec...
une tasse de café dans la main.
Vous pouvez en trouver plein des comme ça
sur le Net
Ça change un petit peu, justement,
des Darwin
Et je pense que ce n'est pas encore
très connu
donc j'espère que ça vous aura
fait marrer.
Si c'est le cas, n'oubliez pas de liker
Vous pouvez vous abonner
comme d'habitude.
Une vidéo tous les 2 jours cet été
jusqu'au 30 août.
Donc, rendez-vous
après demain...
Après demain.
Ciao !
[Musique du Générique de fin]